bonjour bienvenue d'un point de vue
bienvenue à tous qui nous suivaient
n'hésitez pas poser votre question
interpeller nos invités au sommaire de
ces cinquante prochaines minutes le
terrorisme et les questions qui se
posent après l'attentât de marseille
elles sont nombreuses mais aussi le
débat sur la montée de l'islam au
gauchisme débat qui se résument ainsi
une partie de l'extrême gauche est-elle
complaisante vis-à-vis de l'islam
politique
autre sujet un retour en terrain connu
pour emmanuel macron ou ampoules lancé
jean damien et enfin la catalogne
l'avenir de l'espagne en pointillés
depuis dimanche et l'europe qui
observent chaque étape se demandant quel
sera le suivant sur la liste
bonjour à tous les quatre merci de
participer à ce débat bonjour adélaïde
zulfikarpasic directrice bba opinion à
côté de vous jean marc four bonjour
bonjour à puce directeur de la rédaction
de france inter france inter vous avez
reçu ce matin le ministre de l'intérieur
gérard collomb dans le contexte héros
risque ont évoqué vous allez nous en
parler en face de vous le figaro
représenté par vincent trémolet de
villers où jean vincent rédacteur en
chef des pages débats opinion vous
publié ce matin une interview de
jeannette bougrab
l'ancienne femme politique aujourd'hui
essayiste interview titre et malgré
l'attentât de marseille le déni continue
et le figaro encore avec marc landré
bonjour marc rédacteur en chef et
responsable du service économie france
du figaro et le terrorisme d'abord avec
cette question pourquoi le terroriste de
marseille était-il en liberté 24 heures
avant de commettre son attentat il était
aux mains de la police
malgré ses 12 ans de séjour irrégulier
en france c'est cette identité
différente et ses multiples vols alors
fais ton preuve de laxisme vis-à-vis des
clandestins clandestins qui jusqu'à
présent il faut le préciser n'était pas
le profil type des terroristes pour le
député les républicains eric ciotti il y
a une forme d'impunité inacceptable on
le regarde et on en parle il ya un état
d'esprit qui depuis des années fait
qu'aujourd'hui l'éloignement des
étrangers en situation irrégulière n'est
plus une priorité le gouvernement
socialiste avait supprimé le délit
de séjour donc on peut plus placer une
un étranger en situation irrégulière en
garde à vue et le texte qu annonce
gérard collomb maintient cet état de
fait c'est une faute donc nous disons
aujourd'hui qu'il faut réarmer l'état
aussi dans cette volonté de dire ceux
qui n'ont pas un titre de séjour légal
n'ont rien à faire sur le territoire
national jean marc four question simple
comment le gouvernement peut-il
expliquer à l'opinion et aux familles
des victimes que le terroriste était
relâché ben c'est compliqué de
d'expliquer à l'opinion après la
critique est aisée l'art est difficile
c'est à dire que c'est précisément un
peu ce qui expliquait gérard collomb sur
france inter ce matin vous lisiez le
ministre de l'intérieur était notre
invité est ce qu'il dit est ce qu'il
disait y compris d'ailleurs off avant le
avant l'interview à l'antenne c'est
c'est que on est en présence de
quelqu'un en l'occurence qui est passé
de tunisie en italie avec un visa dûment
tamponnée par les autorités tunisiennes
de carthagène et après des papiers en
italie qui sont on va dire en règle au
regard des autorités italiennes tally où
il avait fréquenté des milieux déjà tu
as dit oui et non clairement mais ce que
je sais c'est que c'est que
la situation est compliquée en termes de
suivi du bonhomme et du fait qu' il est
temps on va dire en partie en règle au
regard des autorités européennes premier
point deuxième point deuxième difficulté
c'est tout bêtement vous lisiez
d'identifier son état civil
c'est quelque chose de très prosaïque
c'est à dire que cette identité
defacto et pour pouvoir l'expulser
correctement encore faut-il établir
clairement son état civil
et ça n'a pas l'air si simple c'est
d'ailleurs en partie pour cette raison
parce que son état civil n'était pas
clairement établi que vous l'aurez
observé le ministre de l'intérieur s'est
pas vraiment exprimé jusqu'à ce matin il
a attendu près de 48 heures parce qu'en
fait il le reconnaît c'est lui-même ce
matin dans les couloirs de la radio et
il n'était pas en possession
d'informations suffisantes pour avancer
sur le dossier donc pour vous répondre
compliqué de les expliquer à l'opinion
mais mais en même temps passez moi
l'expression macro niel c'est vrai que
c'est compliqué de le faire ce n'est pas
si simple
pas si simple sont envolés ça vous
paraît une explication qui pour lui
c'est un pis pour le poids non ce que ce
que je pensais que cette complexité qui
a été très bien décrite participer
renforce le sentiment qu'on les opinions
publiques sur l'immigration légale
l'état ne contrôle plus rien en fait
c'est à dire que les gens ont en tête un
certain nombre de règles simples
alors eric ciotti exagère un peu parce
que la première règle c'était quand il y
avait un étranger en situation
irrégulière qui commettait une faute ou
un délit ou un crime ils étaient envoyés
chez lui depuis la suppression de la
double peine faite par nicolas sarkozy
ça n'est plus le cas donc ça c'était le
cas de l'attentât de nice par exemple
et puis avec le cas de l'attentât de
marseille on a quelqu'un qui est en
situation irrégulière donc qui ne
devrait pas être la perception commune
c'est celle ci ensuite quand on se
plonge dans les réformes juridiques dans
les décisions de la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme on arrive à la
complexité qui vient d'être décrite mais
cette complexité
il elle est insupportable au fait
entendre quand on voit les conséquences
qu'elles mènent donc et ça rejoint
au-delà du terrorisme le problème j'ai
un peu l'impression de répéter ce que
j'ai déjà dit sur ce studio que
qu'hubert védrine avait dit en ces
termes et que je répète les autres les
opinions publiques ont l'impression que
les états ne contrôle rien et c'est dans
ce domaine précis
une permanence et vous rappeliez le
contexte de la loi c'est vrai qu'en 2012
on a supprimé le délit de séjour pour
pouvoir ce que ce délit puisse s'exercer
il faut qu'il ait une flagrance c'est à
dire qu'il faut quand le mental la
frontière donc en fait il n'ya pas de 4e
classe et payet a pris voilà la paperie
marchanderait on peut résumer ça comme
ça 6 puis il a été pris il a été vu mais
il a été relâché parce qu'il y avait un
dysfonctionnement administratif
effectivement comme vous l'avez dit des
problèmes pour ea ne serait ce que pour
connaître son identité parce qu'il ait
pas de place là où devait aller puis
avait une vacance de je crois aussi du
juge ou de l'administratif qui est
échappé même pu recharger
c'est quand même c'est que ce qu'elle
terry parce que mes études explique al
c'est inexplicable je vais pas dire et
d'excusés mais c'est inexplicable quand
on voit qu'il ya deux gamines de 20 et
21 ans qui au final ont été assassinés
je veux dire voilà donc aux essais en
plus justification qu'on veut il se
trouve qu'au final il ya deux morts deux
jeunes femmes qui avait rien demandé qui
était qui sont décédés et donc toutes
les justifications du monde ne
permettront pas de l'expliquer soucier
ce fossé effectivement il est entre le
pedigree entre guillemets précédent du
terroriste et puis les actes qu'il a
commis
comment à l'opinion peut le percevoir
alors on a finalement la question c'est
que c'est un petit peu lambda dans la
masse des clandestins qui commet des
actes effroyables
en fait on est sûr j'en étais sûr un
sujet un petit peu explosif ici et c'est
d'autant plus compliqué à expliquer à
l'opinion qu'on est à la croisée de deux
problématiques qui sont ultra sensible
pour les français et qui font partie des
préoccupations majeures
la question de l'immigration et la
question de la lutte contre le
terrorisme qui sont deux sujets dont on
l'a vu pendant toute la campagne
présidentielle qui ont vraiment été mise
au coeur des préoccupations des français
après la question notamment de l'emploi
et celle de l'europe donc on a ici deux
sujets très sensibles pour les français
qui sont qui se retrouvent corrélés et
qui rendent les français je pense assez
peu indulgent sur cette question de
temps moins indulgent que pour être il
faut être clair sur les questions
d'immigration et les français sont quand
même une position assez assez dur et
quand on parle de l'immigration
clandestine
ils sont vraiment du côté des
clandestins dans ce contexte là je pense
que la réaction elle est plutôt celle de
on n'a pas fait d'enquêté suite à
marseille mais d'un manque d'indulgence
et de compréhension sur le sujet
effectivement la question du jeu
du figaro qui est attentats de marseille
as tu eu défaillance de l'état pour le
moment les réponses sur douze mille
votants sont à 90 % de oui en même temps
vincent tremblay est ce que la droite on
a entendu eric ciotti ne se trompe pas
un petit peu de cibles parce que dans
les précédents et si on peut établir une
typologie le clandestin qui commet un
attentat c'est pas légions de ces mêmes
une exception oui alors ils vous diront
je suis pas là pour faire leur avocat
mais ils vous diront qu'il suffit d'un
cas et si on avait pu éviter ce quasar
est légitime et que la loi soit
appliquée de façon plus ferme
en revanche si on revient sur la
question de la double peine ya un autre
attentat qui aurait pu être évitée bon
enfin virtuellement si vous voulez qu'il
l'attend à nice puisque la personne
avait été condamnée bon après moi je
pense que la droite a raison de vouloir
marquer fermement les faits comment dire
de de persister dans ce qu'on avait fait
avec l'état d'urgence c'est-à-dire de
maintenir une espèce de tension qui
existe dans les faits qui existe dans la
population et que tout ce qui pourrait
donner l'impression d'un relâchement
participerait de l'inquiétude collective
alors vous parlez de l'état d'urgence
gérard collomb l'a dit est l invité de
france inter ce matin lui il parle
d'état de guerre on va l'écouter et puis
on voit le niveau de la menace en france
est extrêmement important et que toutes
celles et tous ceux qui pensaient que
finalement les choses étaient terminées
et qu'il fallait desserré finalement la
capacité de nos services à aller de
l'avant a essayé de regarder d'avoir des
renseignements et ils se trompaient
parce que oui nous sommes toujours en
état de guerre même si des ch a connu
des défaites militaires marc four état
de guerre dit le ministre de l'intérieur
et en même temps on lève l'état
d'urgence dans un mois oui bon c'est une
formule 1 c'est une formule de politique
façon état de guerre je suis pas sûr
qu'on sera en état de guerre mais bon
peu importe peut jouer sur les mots
toute la difficulté à laquelle ils sont
confrontés d'ailleurs comme les
gouvernements précédents m'a peut-être à
fortiori parce que la menace ne cesse de
semble-t-il de s'amplifier
c'est que les contours de la menace sont
floues on le disait là en l'occurrence
évidemment qu'il faut tout faire pour
éviter ces assassinats et ces attentats
odieux et insupportable pour tout le
monde reste que la le profil
dugas c'est plutôt un sdf avec un
pedigree de droit commun quand même plus
proche du droit commun que que du
terrorisme
oui je suis d'accord pas le messie
rouler mais qui s'était réglé pense que
dans les fichiers policiers j'ai pas
accès aux fichiers policiers mais
j'imagine qu'il est plutôt dans ce
plutôt fléchés de ce côté là donc
comment vous les repérer on voit bien
que c'est extrêmement difficile et 2 est
deuxième difficulté
pardon là encore de deux lettres une
certaine façon prosaïque trop prosaïque
probablement mais on sait qu'on efface
aussi avec la question des clandestins
sur une histoire de un peu de rocher de
sisyphe de tonneau des danaïdes c'est à
dire que vous là il arrive précédent par
l'italie voulez vous les expulsés par la
porte et revienne par la fenêtre
enfin nous on a tous des jeux m'a fait
des reportages là dessus et à la
frontière franco italienne s'est
beaucoup ça vous les fait sortir par un
train et puis ils repassent par un
camion d'envoyer c'est vrai que c'est
vraiment ton et les mots c'est compliqué
on a il ya quelque chose d'intéressant
il parle d'acte de guerre et c'est vrai
que quelqu'un qui tue des civils avec un
cri de guerre qu'il a prononcées qu'à
allah ou akbar et qui est tué par un
soldat on est si on détaille dans un
acte de guerre mais là où il ya quelque
chose de déroutant pour le punir public
si ce n'est pas révoltant c'est que
quand on se plonge plus profondément
dans cette affaire on s'aperçoit que
c'est une question de sécurité publique
au fait est que cet événement aurait pu
être empêché si la chaîne administrative
avait avait fonctionné
effectivement vous rappeliez là le côté
puis s'en fout un peu
quelques chiffres qui m'était donnée par
christophe cornevin notre spécialiste
poli sécurité avant l'émission
il y a environ 300 à 4 350 mille quatre
cent mille étrangers en situation
irrégulière en france
devant c'est une estimation et sur cent
cinquante mille procédure pour
infraction à la législation sur les
étrangers
il y en a seulement 3500 qui sont
exécutés hors espace schengen mais ont
rejoint ce que vous disiez jean-marc crc
les véritables expulsion puisque le
reste on les dents
ali en belgique normalement oui pardon
del conte ce pilote et de refiler le
tueur nos voisins c'est pas très pressés
devant une solution n'a pas envie qu'ils
tuent davantage en italie enfin je vous
propose aussi d'écouter maintenant marc
trévidic marc trévidic l'ancien juge
anti-terroriste qui regrette lui
l'absence d'une politique de
déradicalisation il était ce matin sur
rtl
une loi ne règle pas un problème notre
problème c'est les jeunes qui se
radicalise ce n'est pas c'est pas
simplement traiter les effets il ya les
causes les causes ou ce que vous voulez
il faut s'en occuper on a oublié au plus
personne parle de déradicalisation c'est
comme si on avait abandonné l'idée qu'on
puisse faire quelque chose avec des
jeunes qui se sont radicalisées moi je
pense pas qu'il faille abdelli on n'a
quasiment rien essayé ce qu'on est
d'accord pour mettre des moyens pour
éviter de construire des terroristes en
maison d'arrêt par exemple parce que
c'est bien gentil tout ça mais ça sert à
quoi si on en fabrique nous mêmes des
terroristes ou on n'en fabrique plus qu
on en arrête
adelheid effectivement déradicalisation
donné beaucoup parlé il ya encore un an
et puis plus rien il ya eu des échecs et
puis on fait terminé c'est sans doute
une erreur de ne pas avoir persévéré
en tout cas du point de vue de l'opinion
publique oui parce que c'était vraiment
une des priorités il faudrait juste
rebondir strauss kahn dit jean marc four
il a dit qu'il était un peu prosaïque
les français sont aussi sur la question
de la lutte contre le terrorisme ce
qu'on a vu enquête après enquête que ce
soit pour le gouvernement actuel ou 20
ans précédents
c'est un des rares sujets d'action sur
lesquels les français ont confiance dans
les gouvernements quels qu'ils soient
mais ils font preuve d'un certain
fatalisme en dix ans quoi qu'on fasse
sur un peu voilà ya forcément des ratés
le risque zéro n'existe pas et on peut
pas voilà qui sont très pragmatiques et
quand on leur demande juste ont les
moyens de lutter contre le terrorisme ce
qui sortait en premier lieu ces derniers
mois c'était effectivement traiter le
mal à sa racine et donc devrait
notamment sur la question de la lutte
contre la radicalisation donc oui c'est
que tu c'est une priorité pour l'opinion
et laisser de côté cette taxe de travail
pour être un choix critiquable il ya une
autre tentative terroriste enfin là
c'était une tentative qui a été sans
doute des jouets mais fortuitement c'est
celle de la bombe enfin ces bonbonnes de
gaz
retrouvez le channel dans le 7ème à
paris effectivement c'est fortuit là
d'autres il ya quelques semaines c'était
un artisan qui était tombé sur un
appartement où on fabriquer des
explosifs
le contexte est de plus en plus si l'on
en croit
différents ministres de l'intérieur qui
se sont succédé des là où on le sait
mais il y en a beaucoup qui sont
empêchés sans que nous soyons qu'on
rentre donc la menace elle et elle est
toujours aussi importante d'après les
spécialistes et notamment gilles kepel
elle a muté c'est à dire que la grande
opération de type 13 novembre est plus
compliqué à monter parce que les
services secrets ont deux réussi à
décrypter un certain nombre de de
messagerie et a identifié un certain
nombre de personnes mais ce qu'on
appelle le terrorisme locaux c'est à
dire ce qu'on a vu à marseille vous ce
qu'on peut voir avec une voiture et est
encore une menace extraordinairement
présente et il se trouve que la victoire
d'emmanuel mac qu'on a fait on a fait
oublier peut-être parce qu'on a été sur
des sujets économiques du fait de la
nouveauté de la jeunesse du début de
mandat
7 cette inquiétude qui traverse la
population française et qui n'a pas
disparu au fait avec le changement de
deux présidents et deux gouvernements et
on a très peu parlé pendant la campagne
présidentielle
ce qu'il fait c'est surprenant au sortir
de la séquence 2015 2016 alors un thème
polémique celui là celui de la gauche
rallye radical était supposé
complaisance avec l'islamisme
une députée la france insoumise qui
parle de sexisme plutôt que de
radicalisation quand on lui demande de
qualifier l'attitude d'un chauffeur de
bus qui refuserait de prendre le volant
après sa collègue féminine cette
séquence a enflammé les réseaux sociaux
et ravivé la polémique sur la
complaisance donc supposé de s'être
gauche radicale voici donc ce qu'en
disait danièle obono c'est elle la
députée mélenchonistes de paris des
propos qui on peut s'inscrire à l'écran
est ce que quelqu'un qui refuse de
conduire un bus après une femme doit
être mis sur écoute perquisitionné mis
ensemble de rétention s'interroge
danielle obono qu'ils poursuivaient
refusant d'établir un parallèle entre
pratique religieuse et habitudes
est ce que c'est en fonction de ses
croyances religieuses ou est ce que
c'est en fonction de ses habitudes et
zettel de ce cet exemple du chauffeur de
bus on ne se pose même pas la question
on peut être sexiste et religieux ou pas
croyant effectivement des propos qui ont
fait beaucoup réagir
alors jean marc pour manuel valls at il
raison on va l'écouter on va d'abord
l'écouter quand il parle d'une partie de
la gauche qu'elle n'a qui tue plus
qu'envie où les coups depuis un an par
une partie de la gauche parti de la
gauche a failli sur ces questions les
retail dans la complaisance de vie du
communautarisme
on voit bien qu'il ya des parlementaires
de la france insoumise qui aujourd'hui
ont une attitude plus qu'ambiguë est en
tout cas quand tu tiendras madame au
bono qui dimanche considère notamment
que un chauffeur de bus qui refuse de
prendre son service après qu'une femme
les précéder que ça ne pose aucun
problème
voilà c'est dit c'est fait sexisme ces
seuils soient brige la mise voilà bon ce
sont ces c'est une forme de banalisation
permanente qui me choque et que je veux
condamner ou finalement manuel valls
d'un côté eric ciotti de l'autre sont
sur la même critique de 7
c'est un sujet qui monte progressivement
depuis j'ai lu il ya une dizaine
d'années quand même en réalité un à peu
près 7 que cette question de l'islamo
gauchisme enfin cesser c'est à peu près
ça le
le vocable qui est employé moi je suis
pas là pour distribuer des bons ou des
mauvais points donc mon sentiment
personnel est de dire que je ne sais pas
s'il ya complaisance vis-à-vis de
l'islamisme l'impression qu'on a c'est
en tout cas il ya des oeillères c'est à
dire qu'il ya un une sorte de déni de
réel et s'inscrivant probablement dans
une
j'essaie de comprendre dans une logique
de de décryptage du monde qui s'inscrit
dans une tradition marxiste où tout est
ramené au social on va dire enfin je
vais vite à mais bon tout est ramené aux
classes sociales la sociologie à aux
habitudes dixième à la bono les
habitudes
c'est ça on voit bien qu'il ya tout un
corpus idéologique autour de ça qui
tente à mettre dans l'esprit que
finalement tout ramène à ça et que
saigner à dire dans quel milieu social
on vit comment les formes et les gens
avec qui on discute et que de ce point
de vue effectivement l'impression qu'on
a qu'on a c'est qu'il y a il y a des
oeillères c'est à dire qu'on ne voit pas
l'autre partie du sujet et s'est essayé
à ni de la résidence de la france et de
la mystique on crie dans le quartier
politiquement il ya du clientélisme
électoral ça on va l'écarter parce que
c'est l'opportunisme du cynisme
mais ça n'a pas de deux de charpente
idéologique en revanche ce qu'on appelle
l'islamo gauchisme a pas été théorisée
parce que personne c'est revendiquer
islamo gauchiste mais c'est un certain
nombre de textes qui rejoignent
exactement ce que vous dites est qui qui
résonne de la façon suivante qui se
disent c'est des marxistes qui se disait
nouveaux damnés de la terre de nouveau
prolétariat est incarnée par les
musulmans et les musulmans sont opprimés
par les ennemis permanent du prolétariat
qui sont le capitalisme incarné en
général par les américains et israël et
la religion chrétienne est donc l'islamo
gauchisme ça c'est jacques julia ce que
je vous dis qu'il a écrit dans le figaro
dans son carnet qu'il tient et qui la
décrit de façon très très abouti à ces
trois ennemis là que je viens de nommer
et pense que le enfin les musulmans vont
permettre de vaincre l'ennemi absolu qui
est le coeur le grand capital et le
capitalisme et donc il y a des pensées
aux france à edwy plenel ou des
journalistes ou même emmanuel todd qui
dans son livre qui est charlie avait
développé cette idée
l'idée de ce nouveau prolétariat qui est
un pro l'état de sa constance je pense
même pas que c'est par bienveillance
vis-à-vis des musulmans mais c'est comme
une arme que l'on utiliserait puisque
les armes précédentes n'ont pas n'ont
pas été suffisamment efficace ça a été
une des lignes de fracture ben oui oui
parce que ça si vous voulez ya eu enfin
on l'a bien vu sous quinquennat de
françois hollande il y avait l'idée que
forcément le musulman où l'immigré
musulman est une victime et ne peut pas
être un agresseur et qu'il est toujours
la victime d'une société qui toute
société patriarcale atteinte chrétienne
pro-américaine capitaliste est donc ce
cette grille de lecture à mon avis
aveugle et un certain nombre de gens
peut-être un certain très sincèrement et
et les a entraînés dans cette déshérités
je ne sais pas on peut pas juger moi je
suis pas là pour sonder les reins et les
coeurs mais il ya entre est d'une
cohérence idéologique dans ce sens qu'on
appelle l'islamo gauchisme ainsi que le
bernard cazeneuve ancien ministre de
l'intérieur au moment des attentats de
2015 a dit récemment ou à ce moment là
nous le gouvernement on a été surpris on
s'attendait à ce que les français se
déchirent cueillette quasiment des des
ratonnades le terme est peut-être un peu
fort mais c'était l'idée ça
effectivement cette bonne tenue du
peuple français en général a été une
surprise
sur la question de sur les questions de
après des attentats successifs c'est sûr
finalement c'est pas si rose que ça
parce que il ya un indicateur qui est
intéressant c'est un baromètre qui est
réaliser année après année par la cncdh
commission nationale consultative des
droits de l'homme qui suit notamment à
la progression des actes racistes des
sentiments racistes et ce qu'on a vu
dans le baromètre c'est que d'une part
les musulmans et l'islam reste la
minorité religieuse entre guillemets la
plus critique est la moins acceptée par
rapport au judaïsme protestantisme
catholicisme avec une critique qui
s'étend de la religion aux pratiques
elle-même et notamment aux pratiques
visible et on a vu une évolution
justement 2015 et en même temps les fils
d'une voie là et en même temps et celle
du ministère de l'intérieur
j'ai vu des données qui montrent qu'il
ya une recrudescence des actes anti
musulmans notamment en novembre décembre
2015 donc enfin voilà la bonne tenue des
primaires salée elle aura pas de votre
votre source documentaire pour cela mais
il ya un certain nombre d'études indique
ce qu'on appelle des actes islamophobes
et donc l'islamophobie part du principe
que toute critique de l'islam participe
de l'islamophobie pour ça que la télé
toute critique du christianisme ou le
judaïsme ou du bout dit
ne fait pas monter l'antisémitisme et
actes antichrétiens et c'est là qu'on ne
sait pas si une personne qui par exemple
à qui on demande de ne pas avoir de
signes religieux considèrent ça comme un
acte islamophobe et fait monter les
statistiques c'est ça qui qui qui
participe de la confusion dont je
parlais du sentiment victimaire qui se
développe dans une partie de la gauche
et de l'extrême gauche
il ya à mon sens quand même un double
risque de chaque côté c'est à dire que
d'un côté on l'a évoqué les ollières sur
la menace et la prégnance de l'islamisme
radical fait que on peut être conduit à
nier un centre de réalité pourtant
évidente
y compris d'ailleurs un corollaire qu'on
n'a pas cité mais qui est
l'antisémitisme qui est quand même très
prégnant que louis avec des conséquences
je dis ok donc et mais de l'autre le
risque de la posture inverse cessé de
nier qu'il y a de fait aussi en france
aussi c'est comme ça ce n'est pas
incompatible c'est une réalité de la
société française il ya aussi des actes
islamophobes premier point les deuxième
point attention ne pas tout ramener
toujours à la menace islamiste
elle est indiscutable elle est réelle on
le voit tous en même temps marseille
malgré tout il ya une question las vegas
nous n'en parlons pas il n'y a plus
qu'une question donc il faut se méfier
de du risque inverse aussi de tout
ramener à la menace islamiste même si
elle est très forte
parmi les remarques ou réaction je cite
celle de babeuf qui nous dit les
insoumis ne parle pas de mesures
antiterroristes dans leur programme ils
ne prenons jamais les mots islamisme
radical
vincent trémolet ce matin l'interview de
jeannette bougrab était intéressante sur
de multiples points de mai notamment l
analyser le phénomène en dix ans la
gauche a préféré taire la dimension
religieuse du nationalisme algérien
monté à la guerre d'indépendance et
rappelant que les combattants à l'époque
devait observer un islam rigoriste
c'est une analyse historique intéressant
qu intéressante qu'elle est qu'elle a
puisé dans le l'excellent livre de jean
bien debout qui s'appelle un silence
religieux et qui analyse cette cet angle
mort et au fait pourquoi parce que c'est
la grille de marxistes ou jours qui fait
que la dimension religieuse d'un combat
ne peut pas être appréhendé parce que ce
combat ne peut avoir que des causes
économiques et sociales
d'où d'ailleurs le fait que les
attentats sont d'abord des causes
économiques et sociales et pas des
causes religieuses
or c'est une erreur on l'a vu avec un
certain on l'a vu avec la plupart de
ceux qui ont commis des attentats en
france
il avait des vies je pense à médicaux
libanais par exemple il avait un métier
il avait voyagé il avait un niveau de
vie qui était le niveau de vie qui était
tout à fait supportable
donc cette recherche cette grille
marxisante a fait qu'un certain nombre
de gens à gauche n'ont pas vu le
djihadiste comme un sujet à part entière
de l'histoire qui croit à des choses et
qui les défend et physiques pour ça est
prêt à tuer est prêt à mourir mais
commettre cette erreur il ya 25 ans et
d'une chose au moment de gia et c'est
effectivement de c'est une chose parce
que à l'époque on n'a peut-être pas tout
à fait conscience du fait que
effectivement cette poussée de
radicalisme religieux et est en fait
complètement souterraine est en train
vraiment de sortir on le réalise pas
nécessairement c'est une chose et 25 ans
commettre la même erreur aujourd'hui
c'est autre chose
un ami me semble-t-il c'est y pas que ce
n'est pas non plus une posture dont
s'est dit ce type de déclarations du peu
sûr vous disais tout à l'heure vient
pour faire d'un pôle clientélisme
politique c'est vraiment des convictions
à moi je pense que pour certains ce sont
vraiment des conditions c'est à dire que
la la volonté d'aboutir à un projet
politique définie qu'est la mort du
capitalisme pour aller vite et de ce que
de l'univers qui l'accompagnent et a
trouvé une nouvelle force un nouveau
levier avec
avec l'islam et donc moins pour certains
c'est une vraie idéologie pour d'autres
dedans il ya des idiots utiles
il ya des gens qui pensent bien fait
enfin il ya 50 nuance l'islamo gauchisme
si vous voulez patricia lowe celle qui
nous a rejoint nous dit tous les
gouvernements successifs ont été
laxistes sur le sujet et la gauche plus
que les autres n'est ce pas
c'est son avis elle poursuit je vous
invite à venir dans une banlieue comme
trappes dans les yvelines et vous
comprendrez le clientélisme de nos élus
whirlpool maintenant une longue
discussion apaisée avec un syndicaliste
cgt les images de la visite des manuels
macron ce matin à amiens sur l'ancien
site de whirlpool et phase celle de la
campagne avec ses pneus brûlés et les
invectives de la foule est ce suffisant
pour qu emmanuel macron devienne le
président des pauvres
amiens et ses emplois sauvés sont-ils
l'arbre qui cache la forêt de la
désindustrialisation en france je vous
propose d'en parler finalement parkland
ray cette visite d' emmanuel macron
c'est plus un coup de com de la
récupération ou les bienfaits de sa
méthode
expliquez aux français je vois pas trop
quelles seraient les bienfaits de ces
méthodes ou quelle serait sa méthode en
matière de ou sur le cas précisément un
pool foule ce qui l'a semble-t-il tenté
d'expliquer nous envoyer ma méthode dans
la loi travail et tout ça voilà les
bénéfices qu'on peut en tirer dialogue
national le plus long sauf que voilà il
ya là il s'est auto logique ce qui s'est
passé avec moi le foot n'est pas lié à
emmanuel macron n'est pas lié au fait
qu'il y soit les pendant la campagne
présidentielle
le fait qu'ils aient retrouve qui s'est
trouvé un repreneur c'est parce qu'il y
avait une loi qui avait été très
critiqué y compris par emmanuel macron
quand il était au gouvernement qui se
disait que une entreprise qui cède ainsi
tu dois trouver un repreneur et c'est la
direction d'entreprise qui a co qui a
qu'eux qui a qui a appelé énormément de
potentiel repreneur pour et ils ont
trouvé un il se trouve que c'est le cas
yeux monsieur cailleux qui est dirigé
vers karajan picard également qu'a
décidé de récupérer le site
donc je vois pas en quoi emmanuel macron
et pour quoi que ce soit dans le fait
que donc c'est de la récupération c'est
la récupération c'est de la com où il
pour ça il est très fort d'ailleurs il a
juste tenu parole c'était qu'ils avaient
comme ben oui il avait dit il avait dit
je reviendrai il est revenue savait pas
lui ôter sa forme après effectivement ce
qui est exact c'est que c'est que ça
vient de plus loin et que ça vient aussi
d'ailleurs que bernard cazeneuve a joué
un rôle dans cette affaire que xavier
bertrand a joué un rôle dans cette
affaire que plein d'hommes politiques en
réalité on joue un rôle dans cette
affaire
adélaïde juste effectivement ça paye de
tenir ses promesses pour leur dire on en
rigole mais en fait je pense que dans le
cas présent constamment emmanuel macron
c'est ce qui en ce moment fait son petit
rebond dans l'opinion et à plusieurs
enquêtes noyer notre observateur
politique entre semaine dernière faisait
le point il dit ce qu'il fait et dont on
a vu dans les questions ouvertes
c'est-à-dire batîment que ce qui a
fonctionné chez les françaises ca
capacité à tenir ses engagements à
respecter effectivement c
ses promesses de campagne à ne pas
lâcher face à la pression de la rue et
c'est aussi perçu ça fonctionne parce
que la capacité à tenir ses engagements
c'est le prémice indispensable pour
réformer le pays qui est ce pourquoi les
français qui ont voté pour un agneau
napperons ont voté pour lui donc c'est
un coup de com mais qui vient conforter
une posture qui en ce moment lui réussit
tout cela dit on verra des enquêtes de
clips d'opinion dans quelques jours sur
l'île et sert précisément
oui si les français sont contents qu'il
ait tenu sa promesse effectivement il
l'avait annoncé il l'a écrit c'est pas
un scoop pour personne
on verra si lui tienne crédit du fait
qu'il a effectivement supprimer l' isf
pour créer les filles et le prélèvement
forfaitaire qui consiste à dire c'était
dans mon programme je l'avais annoncé ça
marche plutôt pour l'instant je vais
m'asseoir montrer la sarkozy en 2007
parce que c'est notamment ce qui la fait
qu'il n'a pas changé son programme
justement parce qu'il ya eu la crise et
on lui a plutôt porté au projet
reprocher par la suite d'avoir maintenu
son programme alors que les événements
auraient dû faire que ils l'ont
changerait jean baptiste émergents nous
a rejoint
bonjour cher maître jean baptiste eyraud
fr et vous allez nous dire ce que l'on
dit justement sur les réseaux sociaux de
cette visite
l'ancien site de pôle attention je joue
à arles est désolé pour les grincheux
pessimiste ringard mois à relais de 70
ans
j'admire ce jeune homme emmanuel macron
qui fait tout pour l'avenir de ma petite
fille et en plus il est beau en plus
salées apprend ça sûrement bien navigué
j'en ai un autre lui je ne sais pas s'il
le trouve très beau et un autre donc peu
chick bill qu'est ce qui a sauvé
l'entreprise vieille poule le blabla de
le pen et de rue ferroul action
déterminée d'un maquereau qui tient
parole je demande la ce a rejoint depuis
peu ce que je disais tout à l'heure sur
la parole a besoin ida il avait dit il
le fait tout ce que je disais moi sur la
commune oui j'arrête pour les louanges
j'arrive sur la communication donc fini
des louanges
ils restent minoritaires il faut le dire
l'insoumis car avec lui ironise la loi
travail xxl c'est le cdi de chantier la
facilitation des licenciements encore
pire que le cpe et bacon dit qu'il ne
soutient pas la précarité
ça fait plaisir marque il aime beaucoup
le mot clé oui beaucoup de moqueries un
énième coup de com pour servent on en a
parlé tout à l'heure la visite de
macrohori refoulé parfaitement encadré
que de belles images à la gloire d'un
baratineur bas il y va fort sage encore
plus loin thomas les militants
communistes alors qu'ils saccagent notre
industrie mâcon seront à ouïr le pôle
une opération de communication
totalement indécente et enfin là on
retrouve nicolas dupont aignan
macron veut faire illusion avoué le pool
alors que la politique industrielle
menée est un véritable désastre pour les
intérêts français
ben non on ajoute flore du pont qui nous
dit en quoi macro at il été utile au
fait qu'il y ait eu un repreneur et qui
ajoute qu'elle trouve ce coup de com de
macron plus que bidon vincent j'ai un
élément intéressant comme une politique
voilà je voulais en venir là vous
anticipez et la rencontre avec françois
ruffin douala et l'effet marine le pen
et le vus et et le fait que xavier
bertrand soit venu aussi et je pense que
ça révèle un des problèmes politiques
devant laquelle la droite se trouve
c'est à dire que macro et mélenchon ont
décidé de faire système ils le font très
bien
et à chaque fois le maquereau on
développe et déploie son projet
mélenchon cris en disant que ses hits xl
et que c'est dangereux et la droite est
abîmée donc là que jamais allée verte
décider et voilà ait décidé de remplir
les yeux qu'est ce qu'on va retenir
c'est le face à face mâcon rufin et et
c'est vrai qu'il ya cadre de mâcon
pendant la campagne c'était déjà une le
pen fille et elle est réussie russe fait
en termes d'image et de communication du
jour mais c est oui où est passé le
front national parce que là on a là on
avait donc parce qu'au départ c'est
qu'avant son départ ce levier un petit
peu mais ce qui se passe cet événement
c'est ça le 26 avril
c'est donc emanuela qu'on avait prévu en
termes d'organisation d'aller voir les
syndicats à voir le paulista et puis
marine le pen improvise alors pour le
coup un coup de com vraiment un hâle est
accueillie en grande partie par des
militants du front national emmanuel
macron se voit donc préfecture un tas
dernière facture lui exactement endroit
un truc très institutionnel il se voit
contraint il a l'habileté d'avoir cette
pensée stratégique tactique en tout cas
de dire je vais y aller aussi sur le
terrain parce que sinon je vais me faire
déborder bon mais on se retrouve avec
une journée qui est un face à face
marine le pen emmanuel macron indiqué un
des tournants la campagne habitées
françois ruffin déjà existant a été
présent sur le site déjà des acteurs
c'est pas du titien dans cette heure
alors la scène aujourd'hui que l'image
qu'ils aient beaucoup relayé aujourd'hui
c'est effectivement ce face à face entre
emmanuel macron et françois ruffin et on
retombe sur un sujet qu'on a déjà abordé
ici c'est que finalement on a
l'impression que l'opposition est bon
c'est des insoumis et et xavier bertrand
qui effectivement passé un peu au second
plan un peu même si lui souligne
notamment devant dallas droit à la même
l acompte tenir ses promesses
cette préoccupation c'est lui tendrais
c'est quoi des acquis déjà tendu c'est
de faire venir des entreprises en ce
moment elle dans sa région
hélas pour le pôle où pour le coup lui
il mouille la chemise véritablement
c'est pas des coups de com qui fait il
va chercher avec les dents
les entrepreneurs les entreprises pour
créer des emplois véritablement dans sa
région
donc effectivement aujourd'hui sur la
séquence communication très bien
orchestrée par l'elysée est très bien
orchestré par la france soumise à
travers françois ruffin il en est
effectivement exclu mais concrètement
sur le terrain
il a plutôt quelques résultats alors
après faut voir d'où il part gère les
autres ans c'est 13 % de taux de chômage
donc effectivement quelques résultats
qu'ils puissent avoir ce sera très
compliqué à porter à son crédit parce
que ça reste une terre quand même
socialement relativement ravagé mais
pour revenir sur ce que dit aussi qu'un
des internautes la politique
industrielle
elle va plutôt mieux aujourd'hui et pas
grâce à emmanuel macron n'avait plus tôt
mieux c'est la première année en 2018
qu'on va avoir des créations nettes du
sinn en france on les détruit pendant
plus de dix ans et cette année on voir
plus usine qui s'installe plutôt qu'ils
se détruisent qui ceux qui s'expatrient
sa ses premiers points et le deuxième
point qui est quand même très
intéressant quand on en france on sait
que depuis quinze ans il ya un boom de
l'intérim et qu'il ya une destruction
des emplois industriels mais quand on a
réaffecté l'intérim dans les secteurs
qu'il emploie pour la première fois en
2016 on a eu des créations d'emploi
nettes dans l'industrie c'est une
tendance qui s'est inversée depuis le
début des années 2000 donc je dis pas
que youpla boum c'est génial on va
danser sur les tables non c'est que il
ya une
une inflexion qui commence à se faire
sentir sur l'industrie aussi parce que
toutes les entreprises toutes les usines
qui était défaillante ont disparu donc
maintenant ne résiste ne sont là que
celles qui ont su résister à la crise
mais on est peut-être au début de
quelque chose de nouveau et on verra et
là ça sera la responsabilité d'emmanuel
macron si son exécutif si son
gouvernement si sa politique est capable
de fédérer cette politique ou au
contraire c'est un c'est un mirage
partager l'optimisme de magrin dans
toute la zone est ce que ce que marc
landré tu dis est vrai aussi à l'échelle
ou en le pool puisqu'on retrouve un peu
ce sujet là la position de françois
ruffin france insoumise et de dire
d'accord vous avez en gros réglé par le
pool mais il ya le problème des
intérimaires et des sous traitants via
notamment l'entreprise primat et qu'il a
en gros la position des macros et de
dire oui mais l'intérim et était un
problème qu'il faut résoudre autrement
parce qu'en fait c'est pas des vrais
emplois et donc moi ce que je veux
travailler sur je veux travailler sur
des vrais emplois ou de vous retrouver
ce même débat aller à l'échelle à là on
va dire la petite échelle au warm pool
xavier bertrand il est aussi venu parce
que parmi les grands projets il y en a
certains qui sont plus ou moins en stand
by
abandonnée on sait pas le canal seine
nord en fait partie et c'est un c'était
pourvoyeur d'emplois potentiels pour ces
la région oui c'est s étaient abandonnés
on se rend compte que là parce qu' il
fallait bien faire des économies et donc
les financements pour finance ou du
financement de développement du canal
étaient stoppés et l'a visiblement non
une entente pour essayer de redévelopper
ans le nombre de fonds entre les élus
locaux darmana gérald darmanin le
ministre de l'action des comptes publics
je crois qu'il est du coin il est de la
région ont donc laissé des intérêts
politiques locaux à faire en sorte que
les financements se débloque
et il n'y est pas pour rien donc oui ça
va ça va ça va ça va faire de toute
manière lentement mais seront elles
aussi cette histoire c'est une chose
qu'on consent depuis longtemps c'est que
la droite sur le plan économique ne peut
qu'apporter des nuances ou à la
polyphonie d'aller faire du train elle
peut elle peut s'épuiser mais il incarne
physiquement la réforme comme on faisait
qu alain juppé incarner physique pendant
impôts dont il est très difficile de
dire il aurait pu faire plus et donc
c'est pas là dessus que la droite peut
espérer retrouver une perspective c'est
pas non plus sur l'école puisqu'elle
aurait nommé à peu près le même ministre
donc il lui reste au fait les sujets
régaliens de sécurité dans d'immigration
et d'identité et peut-être la politique
locale enfin les politiques aux gars et
il est peut-être la question des classes
moyennes supérieures mais il touche pas
par définition mais donc pour le moment
politiquement c'est très compliqué
d'exister économiques analyser le
déplacement des mâles même mâcon ce
matin comme une tentative de donner un
petit vernis social là sont assez ces
jours ci en août 15 et marc-andré c'est
quand même super vêtements ça va
forcément être apportées complètement à
son crédit et les conseils sont pas
dupes sur le côté comme il joue à un
espèce de jeu d'équilibriste un peu
subtil mais effectivement comme on a
aussi senti poindre de manière très
nette depuis ces dernières semaines avec
notamment la baisse des appels la
suppression des commandes des emplois
aidés ce sentiment
et puis s est évidemment ce côté c'est
président des riches
voilà ils essayent de me sentir un peu
la barre de l'autre côté mais là où je
rejoins c'est vrai que pour la droite
c'est compliqué d'exister sur ces
thématiques la revanche est beaucoup
plus surprenant sur le fn en effet et
surtout qu'après la rentrée politique de
marine le pen un peu en grande pompe
avoir haché on a pu s'attendre à ce que
maintenant que voilà que la sphère finit
peau est un tout petit peu derrière
qu'elle reprenne
le livre là-dessus et conseiller manuel
mâcon mais qu'ils auraient plus intérêt
à voir comme adversaire marine le pen
qui est une adversaire plus facile à
battre pour lui que le jean luc
mélenchon qui a quand même une capacité
alors pour l'instant sa capacité de
mobilisation n'est pas très visible
puisque les manifestations sont pas un
triomphe mais mais enfin marine le pen
il l'a déjà battu il a montré en des
bases qu'il pouvait faire face à l ess
est un peu l'adversaire idéal pour alors
parmi les vous n'êtes pas le conseiller
des maï maï macro il y en a un c'est
bruno roger petit set ce déplacement à
amiens la donner lieu à son premier
tweet et j'en ai encore vous connaissez
la teneur de ce tweet mais j'ai pas eu
de noël voilà la promesse a été tenue on
est revenue il ya eu un bon dialogue
social voilà bon c'est le premier tweet
de la nouvelle vie de bruno roger petit
qui est pas du tout dans la même
tonalité que sa vie précédente
en tout cas en termes de tweets oui
parce que la tonalité voilà participer à
ces déplacés rentrent dedans avant alors
le tweet de bruno roger petit qu à voir
apparaître à l'écran tout va bien et
voici
merci beaucoup qu est-ce qu il
exactement je promets de revenir tenue
dialoguer change franc menée dans une
ambiance sereine et respectueuse
il manque plus que le timing il y avait
il à vivre est un devoir pour lille
pourrait parler de lui mais comme unique
au visage et aux mains
bruno roger petit qui était quand même
un apôtre de du clash des formules un
peu forcée acheter un bescherelle parce
qu'il n'a pas fait de faute de grammaire
dans sa phrase fc sète caustique mc oui
on peut les voyez on peut dire ça mais
en tout cas ça veut dire qu'il est il
est il et il est bien payé pour faire un
bon coup et alors le projet loi
antiterroriste qui était donc en
discussions en fin d'examen à
l'assemblée vient d'être adopté on va
parler de la catalogne maintenant il
nous reste un petit peu de temps
quarante huit heures après le référendum
organisé par les indépendantistes c'est
la grève
général en catalogne aujourd'hui
l'espagne elle reste suspendu à l'avenir
de cette province
l'europe aussi une europe qui paraît
impuissante diviser chaque état voit
midi à sa porte et hésitent à se mêler
d'une question qui relève de la
souveraineté espagnole
gérard collomb en a parlé ce matin
c'était toujours sur france inter ce que
je comprends si vous voulez c'est que
aujourd'hui vous avez à travers le
territoire d identité forte et que
l'état ne peut plus être nulle part en
europe me semble-t-il un état jacobin
qui veut tout imposé jean-marc faut vous
pouvez décrypte un peu les propos de
gérard collomb qui souhaitaient base des
propos de gérard collomb ne serait ce
que parce que je sais je sais non ce que
je sais c'est que l'europe allait me
paraît pas diviser l essai elle est
paralysée verser m'oublie face au
c.africain viser l'europe face à la
catalogne elle et elle elle est
incapable de faire quoi que ce soit en
réalité voilà lé là elle regarde elle
fait rien dix maisons parce que par
exemple la serbie dit mais pourquoi vous
avez applaudi au kosovo est pas et pas
la belgique
il faut faire quelque chose enfin il
s'est quand même une situation très
préoccupant nous on sera demain matin en
direct de nicolas demorand sera en
direct demain matin entre 7h et 9h je
vous l'annoncé de barcelone mais je dis
ça et les médias je pense font le boulot
sur la catalogne mais on a quand même
quelques une situation qui est très
tendue a fortiori après les images de ce
week-end et on a l'impression que de
chaque côté
ça se crispe et qu'on n'est pas du tout
vers le chemin d'une réconciliation
politique c'est quand même au delà de ce
qu'on peut penser des revendications des
uns ou des autres parce que on peut
effectivement penser que la
revendication enfin qui a une identité
catalane et qu'il y à une demande qui a
une forme de légitimité mais d'un autre
côté il ya un état espagnol qui qui dans
son droit quand quand ils disent qu'il
dit donc
mais au-delà de ça il faut sortir de ça
il faut qu' abandonner que si on se
parle qu'ils arrivaient sparling que
fait l'union anglais pourra faire
quelque chose quand même pourrait
proposer une médiation quelque chose mal
me semble je vous dis je trouve que
c'est l'analyse et les m'oublie de
paralyser
ses auteurs yoel nous dit par exemple
pourquoi l'union européenne ne s'est
toujours pas prononcé sur les actes en
catalogne qui viole tous les droits que
même exige de respecter c'est
effectivement ces violences policières
en fins
on comprend pas très bien pourquoi le
gouvernement rajoy a finalement donné un
argument massue aux indépendantistes
mais c'est vrai que je reprends ce que
dit jean marc four on est un peu sur une
problématique durant même temps on voit
bien que sensible alors il ya la
question européenne mais je pense que
même pour les gouvernements prendre
position par rapport à leur propre
opinion publique c'est assez compliqué
ce qui effectivement ya d'un côté la
question des violences policières
le référendum qui est aussi un
instrument auquel les peuples sont
profondément attachés en tout cas les
français ils sont ils sont très pros
référendum
et puis l'autre côté la question la
légitimité de l'état de et du coup vous
avez ici plein de sujets qui sont un peu
explosif et médiatique parce qu'au fait
c'est politiquement cette histoire
passionnante parce que le l'origine et
comment délimiter la procédure donc
comme ils voient que c'est la démocratie
en fait c'est quand même une démocratie
qui n'est pas une démocratie installée
puisque le vote a été interdite par
l'espagne il ya une violence légitime
qui est celle de l'état
alors on lui extraordinairement
maladroite mais qui va prévoir une
explication parce qu'il ya des images et
howett avec le pouvoir de l'image
aujourd'hui la politique comme elles
étaient menées il ya 20 ou 30 ans est
absolument impossible
c'est à dire que rajoy aurait dû préparé
depuis des mois
cet événement est que le matière le
maintien de l'ordre qu'il a voulu
montrer qui est au fait la prérogative
d'un état de droit
aujourd'hui avec la possibilité tout ce
qu'offre la formation continue est
devenu quasiment impossible mais on voit
là que l'europe reste une sorte de
conglomérat d'état nation donc il n'ya
pas d'initiatives politiques à un niveau
supérieur supra nationale et il ya une
peur de remettre en cause la tord ou à
raison il ne porte pas de jugement la
notion d'état nation donc on peut pas
remettre en cause l'espagne puisque
l'espagne se fait partie de ce paysage
d'aitana se faire un peu c'était
jean-pierre chevènement qui disait
dans une interview qu'il a donnée que
les formats mortes et puis surtout lors
grenon girafe dans le figaro de ce matin
fait sa chronique intitulée l'europe au
défi des identités et a mis en parallèle
le discours d' emmanuel macron et la
volonté de souveraineté européenne avec
ce phénomène de réveil identitaire qui
n'est pas seulement national au fait qui
est parfois religieux et parfois
régionales comme le montre la catalaunie
c'est vrai que face à ça la commission
européenne a l'air complètement perdu
parce que il ya maintenant trois niveaux
de forme politique avant d'arriver à
cette fameuse souveraineté mais
effectivement les manuels maquereau a
passé un coup de téléphone à mariano
rajoy pour lui dire que quand on sait
que c'est juste pour signifier qu
effectivement la souveraineté espagnole
reste le principe mais ça peut aller il
peut aller plus loin moi je vois pas
comment il peut pas ne pas soutenir
il ya pas de choix il n'a pas le choix
même si en coulisses il ya de toute
évidence aussi des contacts et le bar
c'est normal en termes diplomatiques
avec avec monsieur bush de monde et qui
représente l'autorité catalan et qui
était quand même un pari à huit jours
c'est elle va pour
acheter des fraises au marché des
marchés donc ça se parle mais en police
et mais l'action officiel reste dans les
choix en fait mais après c'est enfin par
définition la diplomatie c'est l'art de
ce qui se fait pas publiquement enfin
donc ça serait quand même bien qu'ils
aient des initiatives au moins en
coulisses pour essayer de rapprocher les
points de vue sans se faire inquiéter
servir pour essayer d'empêcher la
séparation parce qu'on vous imaginez une
indépendance d'un catalogue je suis pas
spéciaux de roy commune sur la liste
mais je pense que le reste je pense
s'ils veulent adhérer à l'union
européenne il faut une âme et des
limites et donc l'espagne ne la votera
pas donc ils ne pourront pas donc fois
qu'ils trouvent un statut enfin on
arrive quand même dans des situations
qui vaut mieux éviter donc j'imagine que
la diplomatie français ils travaillent
assad n'a qu'une soixantaine de
maquereaux il n'a pas envie que
effectivement il ya une indépendance en
cas d'aval parce que ça pourrait faire
tache d'huile à bâle autre côté des
données des idéaux face au breton est
encore joué mais on n'est pas tout à
fait sûr je n'ai pas de raison de
l'ecosse ou de la flandre l'ecosse la
flandre vous raisonnez sur denses selon
l'ancien monde parce que maintenant plus
rien n'est comme avant
on a des avis contraires parmi nos
internautes si ce cross qui nous dit de
l'espagne devra aller vers une
fédéralisation à l'américaine une
confédération à la suisse pour sortir de
l'impasse et flo dupont qui revient pour
dire que dans quinze jours on en parlera
plus ce référendum a été votée par les
pro indépendantistes c'est à dire une
minorité il ya le breakbeat aussi qui
dans l'actualité jean-marc faut vous qui
avez été correspondant en grande
bretagne le break site qui finalement le
une chaîne barnier qui dirige les
négociations a dit qu' on en avait pas
fini avec la première phase et que envie
d'aller dans la semoule c'est pas
vraiment surprenant parce que tout le
monde est embêté aussi c'est une patate
chaude et par dessus le marché on a un
pouvoir politique britannique qui lui
aussi est embêté je pense que ça joue
beaucoup
c'est à dire que l'armada mail n'est pas
dans une situation politique très
confortable les contesté au sein de son
parti le congrès d'autoriser des
conservateurs britanniques cette semaine
elle est contestée
parti par boris johnson ils sont pas
unanimes et en fait ils sont pas en
rangs serrés derrière elle donc je pense
qu'elle a un appui politique faible qui
fait que ça ça ça altère ses prises de
position ça retarde les négociations et
ça pourrait durer un moment
vous aurez un moment et on parlait donc
de bain par exemple les causes qui dit
la catalogne devrait avoir le droit de
choisir son propre avenir donc on voit
la joie sion des différentes genre de
questions immédiates il y en a déjà fin
on a déjà publié six ont fui hier box un
papier vendredi après la catalogne est
ce que ce sera la corse alors on peut
dire c'est anecdotique mais il peut y
avoir des revendications sociales y en
aura ce sera mécanique presque disait
cet internaute exact 1 dimanche dernier
ce sont les partisans de l'indépendance
soit parce qu'ils ont eu peur de dire la
grande question c'est ce que leur à
rouhia rencontre se serait présenté
millions et 600 mille personnes je crois
que c'est 90% du oui mais sur 40% du
littoral dont vous voyez que s'il y
avait 80 % du corps électoral voilà on
n'arrive jamais à 100% mais mais 80% si
ça se trouve ce serait en réalité plutôt
55 vaut le maintien au sein de l'espagne
nous la fin du moins c'est ce que
jusqu'à présent les enquêtes 10ème plus
ou moins parlera de la catalogne
prochaine fois sans nul doute
juste une petite info de dernière minute
gérald harman a été exclu des
républicains y avait un bureau politique
des républicains se tenait aujourd'hui
pour le moment en tout cas merci
beaucoup à vous quatre merci à jean
baptiste ces merdes gyan et à tous ceux
qui ont préparé cette émission avec moi
rendez vous demain pour approche un
point de vue présentée par guillaume
brocade
[Musique]